hey everybody and welcome to what is
more or less my Christmas special for
this year I wasn't really sure if I was
going to do something especially for
Christmas but I just sort of felt like
building a quick side project on a whim
and now that you know it's almost
Christmas anyway and I'm planning to
build this in a couple of days actually
just keep it very simple focus on
coaster itself I figured I might as well
go along with the Christmas theme the
only thing is I am not entirely going
exactly with what the game sort of gives
you or what you'd expect with a
Christmas theme that just kind of seems
way too boring for me so instead this
coaster as you might kind of be able to
tell by the name but probably not is
going to have a slight Russian theme to
it the name is actually based on the
Russian word for frost which I kind of
got from an old like winter legend the
only reason that it's sort of weird is
that I decided to spelled differently
than what it originally is just because
it's a bit more marketable this way but
that's really where the name of the
coaster comes from and that's also what
much of the theme will be revolving
around I've been thinking about doing a
Russian theme like this for quite a
while since I just really love those
kind of very heavily detailed wooden
like yeah wood houses that you sometimes
see in Russia but most of them are
really just confined to concept arts or
or drawings from far gone times but it's
it's something that I really wanted to
try it's an interesting style and I
haven't seen anybody try it yet
in planet coaster and it's something
which I loved
to do in rollercoaster kun 3 which some
people might remember there was
Ralphie's Russian wit set which would
allow you to make these kinds of typical
wooden Russian houses and that's
something that I generally want to go
for here of course it will tie into the
Christmas theme in having quite a bit of
Christmas decorations and of course
being a winter coaster to try this biome
but it's not really a traditional kind
of
I would almost say american-style
Christmas theme that you would almost
expect out of most of these cases it's
not very Alpine or North Pole themed
just somewhere in the Siberian woods is
the general idea now this is a floorless
coaster a beam I'm floorless and I
figured I could talk a little bit more
about the kinds of courses which I'm
building because even though I already
do that quite a bit I never really
explained all of the reasoning or like
the the smaller details that you might
not know if you're not as into
rollercoasters so basically these kinds
of coasters are regular sort of sit down
coasters except you don't have a floor
underneath your feet they're made by bnm
which is just a coaster company designs
roller coasters and the floorless
coaster is just very similar to the
standard sort of layout of the coaster
but except instead of having you know
typical cars where you sit inside an
actual coaster car your feet just sort
of dangle outside and I haven't actually
been able to ride any of these they're
super rare in Europe for some reason but
I would love to someday and I do seem
like really cool coasters but they
usually are pretty hard to make and
that's also why I haven't really made
them yet in planet coaster I've messed
around with them a little bit but I've
never been able to make something which
I'm super happy with because they
feature a lot of inversions a lot of
difficult different inversions like not
just loops and cork screws or barrel
rolls but a lot of Sergi rolls in in
moments and that kind of stuff which
I'll get into in the rest of this video
as well but for that reason it's kind of
hard to make it and you could probably
see me struggling right here making this
zero-g roll right here because um here's
my major gripe with making courses like
this and the reason why I sometimes
avoid doing these kinds of things I want
them to be hard lined which means that
the track whenever it does a barrel roll
or a twist or basically it starts
banking it banks around the center of
gravity
Coster basically where your heart is
when you would sit in the coaster so
you're not sort of flinging around the
track and instead this the track sort of
rotates around you as you're sitting
inside the coaster the only problem is
that the smooth tool gets rid of this
heart lining and I need the heart lining
and the smooth tool at the same time in
order to make it realistic being an
flawless coaster and that's what makes
making these things if you want to get
into the custom inversions etc a pretty
difficult challenge and on one hand a
reason why I was kind of avoiding them
but on the other end a reason why this
is kind of good practice because I
really wanted to get into this kind of
stuff so the zero-g roll out of the way
it's not the smoothest thing I just
wanted to make sure that it's hard lined
I sort of see the hard lining is a more
important thing than the smoothing in
this case because if the bnm wouldn't be
hard lined it barely even looks like a
beam in so it's it's a bit of it's a
little bit of a rough sea Ruggiero right
there and then I added the dive loop
over there which is pretty much a
twisting section into a half loop and
after that this little hill with a curve
and at this point I was not really sure
what I was going to do with the rest of
the ride the basic idea was just kind of
finish it with a couple of curves couple
hills and a corkscrew and I was just
sort of puzzling about how I would fit
it in also one reason for that is that I
really wanted to make sure that I sort
of make my way around the supports as to
not delete any of the sports that I
already had but that meant that this
curve had to be stretched out quite a
bit more than I was hoping for in the
end though I just decided to make that a
very large low sweeping curve into a
small airtime Hill over here and after
that into the corkscrew which even after
a couple of times has become one of the
worst cork screws I've ever made not
really sure what went wrong with this
one perhaps I'm gonna have to make it
bigger at some point but for now I'm
just leaving it the way it is after a
couple of tries which is somewhat smooth
but it still has some weird kinks in the
middle of like the transitions until you
go upside down so there are two major
painful bits in this corkscrew that I'll
have to see about at some point in the
future it looks alright
especially from some angles it pretty
much looks like a perfect corkscrew but
there's just like that little part in
the middle where it transitions from the
one node to the other where it just
jerks a bit and next I already wanted to
do a bit of like terraforming around it
it's gonna lie between some hills and
gonna go over a lake over here it's a
little bit like Mjolnir in terms of
setting I mean it's it's also a northern
Europe so that kind of makes sense or at
least I don't have an xx placement in
Russia but it's it's it's somewhat of a
similar kind of environment here so I'll
be having the same kind of no lowly low
hills with all of the rock work and the
pines on top of them it's a bit like a
mule near in that sense
and finally anyway when it comes to the
layout that we have over here I have
that quick little helix coming back to
the break run and that's just about it
there's a very minor hill at the end but
I wouldn't even call it an airtime here
what's just kind of inhale to get back
into the break run and that is pretty
much it I wanted to leave just about
enough space for the break runs actually
slow down the coaster and have a
transfers rack so I had to make it quite
tight at the end there and also a little
bit more terraforming it's gonna be just
about the last for now there's not a
huge focus on terraforming other than
the first drop which is kind of a
special case but I at least wanted to
make sure that there is a bit of a
natural sort of setting in the
background of this coaster which is why
I still wanted to finish all of the
hills around it here and over here and
this is something that probably does
need an explanation
I wanted to make a one of these things
where the cable comes back so the cable
returned and it's something which you
don't get in the game itself but it's
something which very prominently
out on the lift Hills of BMS it's
basically where the cable returns after
it's reached the top of the lift Hill so
you don't have it like running
underneath the track or on the other
side of the little like little chain
thing instead it just runs in a straight
line quite a bit underneath the track
and that's why I wanted to put that beam
there also I wanted to make some custom
looping supports since there was only
one support over here but it looked
terrible and it just sort of destroyed
the image of a PNM since they have very
typical grouping supports and I try to
make one of the supports over here just
there's one problem you can actually
connect them to the coaster track the
hitboxes are very strict and you just
can't touch this thing you can get very
close but it just barely levitates so if
you like look at it from a straight
angle from a very close up as well you
can actually see that the track is
floating and I might do a little bit of
experimentation to see if there are like
different pieces that can connect to the
track in some way but I'm afraid that's
not gonna happen so yeah I suppose we'll
just see how I'm gonna deal with that in
any case I do think these supports do
look a little bit better than not having
any supports at all so I wanted to leave
them in anyway no matter how weird they
might look and also there is the issue
of the path work I mainly wanted to get
into very sort of getting started parts
of working here so making the layout of
the coaster making terraforming but the
paths also also really felt like an
important thing because they sort of
dictates where all of the scenery is
going to be so I also wanted to very
quickly get into the parts lay them out
very roughly this was all just sort of
improvisation to see whatever would work
in these spots it's not the best paths
ever to be honest it's pretty terrible
but it's it's something it's it's a
start
basically I'll try to make it look a bit
better with scenery and see how all
that's gonna work out in the end
now sort of as what I did with my own
air as well I went a bit a bit of time
in actually working on the foliage and
on the rock work of the coaster now I
didn't have much of a look at this
beforehand so this was also just kind of
getting used to what the new trees look
like and what kind of rocks we now have
which was pretty surprising because they
are quite a bit different but there also
aren't that many many of the old rocks
look very dark and kind of stand out a
lot from the icy rocks in this new biome
and there are only two textures when it
comes to the icy rocks and one of them
not a very big fan of looks a bit too
blue in the case of what I'm going for
I'm gonna have a bit more of a brown
dark ish soil texture to it which
funnily enough actually but in the rocky
facades as well I sprayed it with little
bit of that brown soil color just
intensity 10 I believe is the standard
the lowest intensity but just the touch
of brown such a fun bright event light
brown just to make it a little bit more
warm than the cold sort of standard icy
rock that it usually is but anyway so I
use that one rock decided to mix it a
bit with the regular sort of rock and
when it comes to the trees this was even
more challenging I felt since there are
two snow covered trees which is not that
huge of a deal I guess since you know
this is a sort of tundra biome anyway so
why would you need anything but spruces
it just sort of makes it hard to get a
very pallets when it comes to foliage
usually winter foliage it doesn't look
good anyway and even in the theme parks
that do run in in the winter you can
usually tell that you know it's actually
not really made for the winter
especially with many of the trees losing
their leaves and that opening a little
less nice spots in many theme parks and
it's just it's never as colourful it's
never as interesting as having all of
these different colors and four trees
and in this case since we only have two
spruces that makes the amount of variety
that you can
even smaller and it makes it even harder
to actually have some interesting
foliage and not something that's just
sort of there as a way to fill up the
space but that you can very clearly tell
that they're just randomly placed down
trees that are just there to fill in the
space so I just sort of went about
trying to be as careful as I could with
mixing the standard Pines which do have
some snow on them with some of the dead
trees actually to sort of pretend that
there are actual trees then just have
lost out their leaves in the winter and
it doesn't always look like the best
thing it's kind of tough to do this kind
of thing without the trees ending up
looking spooky because that's what
they're kind of meant for I believe but
it's it's all for the winter vibes I
suppose also something to also keep in
mind is that I'll be using a lot of
bushes to at least get some more greens
in here and even though they won't be
snow covered I think that I'll at least
give a bit more variety and a bit more
color into the gentleman landscape and
the same goes for many of the
decorations that we'll be having one of
the great things about Christmas of
course is that we can have lights and
all sorts of foliage details around
buildings as well so that's definitely
something that I'm going to want to play
with to make this look a bit more
interesting than just a dead winter
wonderland anyway that just about wraps
it up for today's time-lapse I want to
thank you guys for watching I hope to
see you guys next time and I'll leave
you with a couple of cinematic shots and
a POV so see you later
the
[Music]
you